million I have been best friends for 15
years ever since not just first day at
school I reckon I live more from Dina
than I ever learned in class join that
five sort of how to do cunnilingus we
did everything together
I loved her
I killed someone sometimes friendship
involves like unpleasant [ __ ] I'm an
awesome friend so I'm always happy to do
that [ __ ] hope you really enjoyed New
Zealand like all that she had to offer
I guess yeah Tiffany watching what do
you get up to last night night it's
chicken
is he a beta you know I just listen get
dev to come away with us this weekend
all right I'm really excited a boat this
place is full of life I'm gonna give you
the best last day ever
Hey in the Catlins yeah give you the
best last day of the Catlins handle
prison dinner you don't go in prison
it's not gonna let anything bad happen a
knowledge
I feel guy Justin getting in there I
feel I get into he's twice
six times bottle call it's like so like
chewy hold us
you know that story where that little
girl rides a while this is far more
amazing because Gabi's really fat and he
was riding a really little dolphin